- [Voiceover] Without gender
the world as we know it
would fall apart.
Without gendered clothes,
choosing an outfit becomes
nearly impossible.
Um, okay so they just pulled
out a shirt they like,
well watch what happens with razors.
This person is using a
non-pink razor on their legs
that will tear her skin to wreck.
Well, she mush have some
sort of leathered skin
or titanium, move along!
The wage gap.
Without gender how would
we know which one to pay
less, hmm?
Watch as anarchy grips these coworkers.
(cha-ching)
They were doing it earlier.
Ah, the big one with
gender neutral bathrooms,
a sexual frenzy would unfold.
What if they heard each other fart?
No, don't open that toy.
- It's the one I wanted.
- [Voiceover] Masculinity will fall.
- My dog just died.
- [Voiceover] Femininity will rise up.
Oh, their bodies are crumbling
under the sheer weight
of the couch.
- Actually, we're fine.
- [Voiceover] Watch pandemonium
take hold of these peers.
The disgusted contempt she
has for people not conforming
to gender assumptions.
- You can't do pastels, here, try magenta.
- Damn it.
- Much better.
- Thanks Hannah.
- [Voiceover] That was
the wrong color for him.
- I knew it didn't look right.
- [Voiceover] He's more of an autumn.
The standards of hand beauty,
handards, handard beauty.